Вимушений креатив на українських дорогах.
Понад 90 відсотків з них
вимагають ремонту або реконструкції.
Це визнають і у профільному міністерстві.
Держава не може з цим самостійно впоратись
і намагається залучити приватні компанії.
Вони відтепер зможуть будувати дороги в Україні,
а потім брати платню за користування ними.
Відповідний закон наприкінці лютого ухвалила Верховна Рада.
Мінінфраструктуризапевняє, що вже збудовані дороги
платними не стануть і мова йде лише про нові дороги,
які зведуть на умовах концесії.
Це форма державно-приватного партнерства,
коли приватний бізнес будує якийсь об’єкт за свій рахунок,
а потім отримує його в управління настрок до 50 років.
Тарифи визначатиме Кабмін з урахуванням рівня інфляції.
Плата за проїзд може суттєво різнитися залежно від того,
де знаходиться дорога, скільки коштів в неї вклали,
наскільки інтенсивний трафік та інших чинників.
За оцінками експертів, вартість може бути від 10 до 20 євроцентів за кілометр.
Це недешево. Для порівняння, у Франції та Італії -
приблизно 15 євроцентів.
Тож, приміром, від Львова до польського кордону
по можливій платній ділянці можна буде доїхати
за щонайменше 10 євроцентів за 1 кілометр,
тобто за 8 з половиною євро,
у перерахунку - приблизно 280 гривень.
Може бути і менше цієї суми.
Щоб ціна "не била по кишені", експерти припускають,
що буде "мікс-тариф", коли водій платитиме визначений урядом тариф,
а решта компенсуватиметься інвестору
з державного дорожнього фонду.
У законі сказано, що дорога може бути платною
за умови забезпечення альтернативного проїзду транспорту безоплатними шляхами.
Їхня довжина не має перевищувати більш ніж удвічі довжину платної автодороги.
Щоправда, є побоювання, що за альтернативними безкоштовними дорогами
навмисно не доглядатимуть, щоб спонукати людей їздити платними.
Буму будівництва нових платних доріг в Україні не очікується.
Надто низькі вантажо- і пасажиропотоки,
які б дозволяли інвестиціям окупитися.
Трафік має бути від 10 до 20 тисяч автомобілів за добу.
Тоді це вигідно. Поки що мова йде про пілотні проекти.
Найперспективніший з них - ділянка Львів-Краковець.
Цей проект презентують вже багато років, втім, особливих зрушень немає.
В "Укравтодорі" сподіваються, що саме ця ділянка
нарешті стане першою концесійною дорогою в Україні.
Це 85 кілометрів від Львова до Краковця на кордоні з Польщею.
Вартість будівництва, за розрахунками "Укравтодору" - близько 600 мільйонів євро.
Інвесторів можуть зацікавити й інші прикордонні ділянки,
а також ті, що примикають до портів,
проект великої кільцевої навколо Києва та
дорога від столиці до Білої Церкви,
якщо ідея звести там аеропорт для лоукостерів таки втілиться у життя.
Закон про концесійні дороги спрощує процедури виділення земельних ділянок,
що дозволить пришвидшити їхнє отримання.
Саме земля завжди була однією з головних проблем для проектів доріг.
За оцінками експертів, мінімум рік іде на виділення земельних ділянок
та ще півтора року – на інші процедури з тендерами,
переговорами і технічно-економічним обґрунтуванням.
Тож будівництво нових платних трас
реально може розпочатися не раніше 2020-го року.